the city of DeNiro Petrovsky lies on the
Dnieper River about 200 kilometers west
of the disputed territories of Donetsk
and Luhansk the fighting in eastern
Ukraine has had a major impact on the
people who live there some like Julius I
gotta say that their lives today are
shaped by patriotism and a sense of
cohesion I grew up on this street and
now I live here too
I used to go walking here with my first
daughter and now I bring my second
daughter here as well young if it's the
bloke I can't imagine living anywhere
else my family and I have traveled a lot
we've tried to live in other places even
in other countries but I just can't I'm
connected to this soil and this river
and they keep pulling me back
Anitra Petrov is the best there is
this city inspires me to carry an active
role as a citizen of achievement
Yuliya is the mother of two children and
a successful attorney and since last
summer
she's been an active supporter of the
Ukrainian army she decided to do that
because of the increase in fighting in
the nearby region of Donetsk Yulia is
one of many volunteers across Ukraine
who collect cash donations and supply
refugees and the wounded with food and
medicine
a ceasefire between rebels and the
Ukrainian army was agreed in February
but some fighting continues so far the
conflict has killed a total of 6,000
people and wounded 14,000 here Yulia
visits wounded soldiers from a battalion
of volunteers I come to the front quite
often to bring aid supplies when I need
soldiers of the Ukrainian army I get the
impression that they don't really want
to fight but the guys in these volunteer
battalions a real fighters would really
appreciate a time to time use project
and beat you we don't get paid for doing
this things are tough the government
just looks after the army without these
volunteers we wouldn't survive if it
weren't for their help I don't know
whether I'd be here right now
system casualty and the Lancia modalism
I had a bad experience with the military
commanders it was the first and last
time I'll deal with them so now we bring
the surprise directly to the unit's
themselves because we don't trust anyone
I'll put your boys coming with the video
that is will look with you today when
it's all it is no there's no ceasefire
we can feel it there's no about the
fighting because it's not covered on TV
they talk about a ceasefire I just come
back from the front and I haven't seen
any ceasefire
are you sure sure good evening
we were fighting around with Hans there
was no ceasefire the fighting continues
the other side is using Russian tanks
like the b3 if you don't lay this
version of the t-72 I saw them myself
they were everywhere and we couldn't
stop them because we don't have any
artillery or heavy weapons unless I come
under yet after the ceasefire was agreed
the army commanders took it all away
it's not a fair fight at all at the when
I think people will eventually see that
this is a nasty and unfair war but all
Ukrainians men women and children will
defend their homes and turn back the
enemy no one here wants to be part of
Russia tour Sybil's is [ __ ] Saddam mr.
Yoshida's receive
the war has become part of everyday life
in Dannette po Petrovsky life appears
normal but the people are tired and
demoralized during the Soviet era the
city was a center of the defense and
space industries relics of the past are
displayed alongside a memorial that
honors Maidan activists who were killed
in civil unrest in late 2013 and early
2014
they're known as heavens hundred
this military tent was put up recently
to provide first aid for people who fled
the fighting in eastern Ukraine natalia
bogna Cova left her home in the donetsk
region last autumn
you haven't ELISA the scene I was born
in Russia but when I was six months old
our family moved to the donetsk area in
Ukraine I've lived here all my life I
went to school here got married and had
two wonderful children but I do love a
shitty night you know so much resting
and then the fighting started I can't
remember when I heard the first shots
every morning at 6:00 the explosions
would start right near our home I saw
Rockets flying over the village I've
eaten look I'm glad the friendly path
but not special
Natalia is a single mother she's now
found a new home for her family in a
suburb of Daniel Petrovsky Natalia got a
job with an aid organization so she can
now provide for her children and her
mother
they're happy that they're now safe they
still remember vividly what the fighting
was like to coach the game is permanent
the children think about it every day
it's scarred them for life but Walt
death they hid in the cellar at my
mother's house they learned pretty
quickly to put on warm clothes and head
down to the cellar it's not least on
Monday my job laughter he played some
football santa came they learned in
kindergarten that when an air raid
starts you've got to hide steam that
doesn't go vitamin let's assume it to me
stone was not rabid sugandha bond that
they often do not a moto I had to go to
work and I couldn't take them with me
that you can you mangu you don't know I
also couldn't leave them home by
themselves as soon as the fighting
started I'd get a call from the
kindergarten come and get your children
we don't have a basement he recalled a
where should we send them I just can't
describe didn't you disguises
I knew she beautiful women the children
were so frightening people winner
the fighting often started while they
were playing outside they ran into the
house and said grandma they're shooting
again or there were explosions I paid to
do then you go it in your studio I ran
inside just like we taught them to well
know what she knew through yet mister do
you oh stop it directed um we go Lyra
her eyes when she remembers all that she
was frightened when gelareh no way Alice
the explosion scared me too
so I ran inside right away yes Lera did
too the conscious I hope all this will
end soon when is Putin going to stomp
it's difficult for me to talk about this
I'm really worried about the people who
are still there I can't say anything I
just want this war to stop just as a
conscience
father Vasily is pastor of an Orthodox
parish in Denia Papa throws now he also
serves as a military chaplain join you
then we'll be long gone you don't win
the look a year when every Friday with a
week that I weigh Lacetti up
boy am I in heat boy and all of us Lydia
went on Paula
so boy a lot Rick on yellow is she
living will be a big boy yourself a
little but you see no locals a lift
Oh
father Vasily and his congregation
support the troops in various ways for
example he carries supplies to the front
himself this is where we store the
supplies that have been collected by
parishioners well for kids that love yes
there's a package of socks for example
our retired couple will have promised
and hit a hundred pairs of socks for the
fighters
grandpa buys the yarn and grandma does
the knitting and she puts a piece of
candy inside each one Yahoo yeah don't
forget to give us idea to that we've got
potatoes cabbage onions all sorts of
food supplies there's sausage and other
kinds of meat people bring every kind of
food you could imagine social shots of
Isaiah we've been doing this for a year
now [ __ ] what the King caught up to you
more
Yaya segeda and her husband Alexander
who's also an attorney are getting ready
to travel to the Ukrainian Army's main
combat zone the government says it's
carrying out an anti-terrorist operation
there the army is running low on many
kinds of supplies we were shocked when
we found out about it there were serious
shortages last summer socks underwear
shoes rangefinders and night-vision
devices did what I let you know what
Virginia we didn't know what we should
buy first is underwear more important
than night-vision devices so he lived
near he stone as the troops had real
fighting spirit and that's what inspired
us to help when we saw how well they
were coping despite the shortages we
knew that we had to do something
we're processing Immokalee positive
emotion you're my girl yes that's aster
I named him ugly at the veneer do it but
then we've been driving to the front
once or twice a week depending on the
amount of supplies that have been
donated girls since last summer when
fighting broke out at the Donetsk
Airport the couple have used their
business office to store aid supplies
Yovani successful teacher scheme worth
during the first two months we spent our
own money we decided that as a family we
wanted to help but then we found out how
much the troops needed we didn't have
enough money to help them and feed our
family so we turned to friends and
relatives word got around about what we
were doing and other people decided to
join us it's just average folks who are
doing this number McGuirk of which
nearly gee me Natasha
I've brought a few trophies back from
the front what did you guys eat all
packages of bandages they were produced
in 1966 or 88 or 91 when I find them I
take them away and replace them with new
ones most appear or Gondorff Eve after
um certainly Greenland Ukraine is not a
military power the army wasn't prepared
for this war I'd go so far as to say
that Ukraine doesn't even have a proper
army it was neglected for two decades
and nearly destroyed huge thought
the government of Ukraine was simply not
prepared for the conflict for example
there was no plan for dealing with
refugees there were no facilities and no
trained personnel
so a group of volunteers opened a
reception center in this big tent not
far from the train station
Andre Marshall a 22 year old Maidan
activists traveled here from Kiev to
help out we're handing out humanitarian
aid to children today it's hygiene
products
maybe cyclists out on some days we get
as many as 700 refugees sometimes people
come here not because they need
humanitarian aid but because they have
nowhere else to go there's no uniform
system for registering the refugees so
that they can get the help they need
they don't know what they're supposed to
do Jessica Lewis dividend it's hard to
speak openly with the refugees they
don't trust anyone they come from a
region where the rule of law has been
violated repeatedly and when the
fighting started people lost their faith
in the local and state authorities is
exceptionally difficult to create trust
did the middle
this facility is located at the tram
depot refugees can stay here for a few
days until they find a place of their
own
volunteers provide essential care for
new arrivals the key question for most
refugees is how to find a job in this
unfamiliar environment they know we've
got social services here and an
employment center where they can find
out what jobs are available most of the
jobs aren't that great but that's the
way it is sure yet the year despite the
ceasefire agreement signed in Minsk in
February 2015
refugees continue to arrive from the
Donbass region many had to leave their
homes in a hurry and now they're forced
to get by on donations it was horrible
I've never experienced anything like it
on the night of February 12th there was
a huge explosion Rockets flew over our
house and hit the kindergarten the
explosion shattered the windows and
knocked everything off the balcony
my son was ill Samia trauma i sat with
him all night in the bathroom we will
eat till you see it it was terrible yes
but an insulin procedure we never got
used to the explosions but she's rushed
on a test rational revocations real
vomit across vaisnavas Musa
Natalya's family lived near the site of
a major battle where pro-russian
separatists routed the ukrainian army
she had made friends with some of the
Ukrainian soldiers that would soon have
dangerous consequences she a fighter
from the 39th battalion called me and
asked whether I could hide two soldiers
one of them was wounded I said sure the
troops waited until it was dark I went
out to meet them we ran through
backyards to get to my place community
men were in bad shape
I wondered man called Sasha had been
shot through the air and had a wound on
his cheek he caused it did they stayed
with me for two days Sasha didn't allow
me to treat his wounds I gave him a shot
of antibiotics antibiotics that was to
reduce the risk of inflammation in the
company who listen to me Valen children
later two volunteers came by and took
the soldiers away our neighbors a couple
of elderly women told everyone what I'd
done and eventually the separatists
heard about it took them the People's
Republic of Donetsk was declared on the
same day as the soldiers left my home so
lost in the Edible soon separatists
arrived and searched
Natalia's house and her mother's house
as well they threatened at Natalia and
demanded to know where the Ukrainian
soldiers were hiding
mr. Charlie's coming in the moon they
pounded on my front door and yelled are
you going to come out or do we have to
come in and get you I said I'm getting
dressed I was asleep
the kids are sleeping don't make so much
noise yeah Lucille and I went outside
they took me to another village nearby
and led me into a cellar relief but both
times we don't really and you will this
macho con man they cursed me and
insulted me they threatened to kill me
and my family if I didn't cooperate just
then I said a warp it we were walking to
the village I said to myself I'm not
going to come back from this later
the rebels allowed Natalya to return
home Ukrainian soldiers helped her to
escape
this weekend just like about every
weekend Yuliya Sagada and her husband
are traveling to the combat zone
specifically the area around donetsk i
live in ukraine and i want my children
to live here too I help the army because
it brings out my maternal instincts I
want my children to live in a country
that's safe and a city that's safe but
right now we're basically living near a
war zone the frontline is only about
three hours away by car when we started
making our deliveries in the summer it
was just two hours it was so awful to
know that the war was just a couple of
hours away we had to do something but
the Botany will he do it
this part of the Donetsk region is still
controlled by Ukrainian troops the
fighting has caused a lot of damage and
has forced many people to leave their
homes
the United Nations estimates that 1.5
million people have left eastern Ukraine
since the conflict began
right now we're close to the military
hospital at Kastner armies it's actually
a mobile field hospital that opened just
recently the hospitals at the front
didn't have room for all the wounded so
they set up a mobile unit here boy I was
with doctors ask Julia and her husband
to bring medicine and surgical
instruments so they did they have to
move fast because they're due to make
deliveries to three more army units dr.
Don of weasely regardless I take
supplies to the mobile brigades first of
all and then I do the rest it's become
really difficult to set up the emergency
dispensaries because all the component
parts have to meet NATO standards
not far from the military hospital
Julia's husband has to stop and fix a
flat tire while she's waiting she meets
some children and hands out some food
parcels that she's brought along thanks
glory to Ukraine again glory to Ukraine
glory to our heroes thanks know there
was lots of shooting missed achievement
even more the talks in Minsk were under
way there was a lot of shooting near the
coal piles nice to taste
did you : it times till we hit the
ground just like our parents told us to
and now things have calmed down
our soldiers are nice to us they give us
stuff and talk to us they don't yell at
us they treat us like we're their own
kids we're not really here that imminent
let me start to drive you to the front
ourselves because a lot of the supplies
were being stolen supplies don't get to
the military Depot's or they're seized
along the way we didn't want that to
continue we've paid for these supplies
with our own money so we want to make
sure that they get to the soldiers who
need them we decided to do it this way
Semyon poker party is the members eat
father Vasily also often visits the
front and going in a combat zone from
the very start because the people from
our parish are fighting there these are
people who were praying with us in
church just the other day then they
leave their homes and families to defend
our independence our country and our
soil we will listen for today's agenda
sometimes they have doubts about what
they're doing because in this conflict
they have to kill people even Orthodox
believers like themselves we go to the
front to give the troops moral and
spiritual support we hear confessions
and we celebrate the Eucharist we see
budget show the troops say that we're
not afraid to be with them even when
we're fired at we go right back the next
day
of course we're concerned about the
danger because each of us has a family
but if we just think about ourselves and
ignore the greater good what does that
say about us mighty God tells us to
sacrifice ourselves for the sake of
others at least the boy who was that I
didn't know you
back at the refugee center some people
have just arrived from Donetsk Andrey
Machoke tries to find them
transportation so they can get where
they want to go many end up staying with
relatives and friends a lot of the
refugees fled because of the fighting
but many also ran out of food and water
and their homes were heavily damaged the
keys vests and the vapors what was it
like out there we beat the window and
frame were blown out we had to cover it
last week it was pretty quiet but the
day before yesterday there was some
firing from the airport which is
occupied by the rebels
but that was a long way off usually it's
really loud at that time it was okay
it's like a big ship in space you gain
will eat I'm an invalid also from August
to October I was in bed with a my favor
I couldn't get down to the cellar
because I had so little strength and
opinion
don't you see mom then winter came it
might sound funny but I had to sell my
gold teeth just to survive that's pretty
funny that's sad but it would be funny
if it weren't so sad
yeah yeah when I came to thee for
patrols
everything was so quiet in fact it was
so quiet I couldn't fall asleep at night
bility huh dude to the people here were
really nice to me my ceiling this city
has now become my home I feel like I've
been living here all along gosh this
doesn't
a state of emergency has been declared
in two new pokrovsky still a rally has
been scheduled to celebrate Ukraine's
independence and above all its unity the
country has developed a new national
identity over the past few months I'm
ready to sacrifice myself for Ukraine
I'm ready to fight on the front line
we've netted avoid the Abdulmalik
oncreate now I've asked myself whether I
should go to the combat zone to join my
friends I want to be there with them but
they won't let me because I have two
children they say I should stay in the
city where I can do work that will help
scarlatina me this knows not enemies it
does this for my guys
it's Little Pony to Ukraine 150,000
people have found a new home in our
region they came to us in an emergency
because of the war in the east the war
forced them to leave their homes big
thanks to all residents of
dniepropetrovsk you've helped these
people find new homes I'm sure that we
will all help them to get settled here
but the most important thing is that
they must be able to return home one day
the highlight of the rally is an
appearance by Ukrainian born singer
Ruslana who won the 2004 Eurovision Song
Contest there's a real Ukrainian spirit
here on this square today Petrovic has
saved Ukraine everyone knows that so
I've come here today to support you in
these uncertain times I want you to know
that Ruslana from the hoof is always
with you
I've come here today because this city
is supporting all of Ukraine and all
Ukrainians know that
watching Naga is me newest our lives
have changed a lot before the war we
were successful attorneys we certainly
weren't poor we will designer clothes
and ate in fine restaurants Brenda
Shankara so Minister Arnhem see just
[ __ ] move it now we don't go out or
buy nice things instead of having dinner
in a restaurant we buy hemostatic
bandages
terney Ches and emergency pharmaceutical
supplies Nikita
so a potato I calculate all my expenses
in terms of hemostatic bandages the city
of Surgeons was briefly occupied by
troops of the People's Republic of
Donetsk the Ukrainian army managed to
take back the city but the rebels
continue to shell parts of it
their positions are located just a few
kilometers outside the city limits these
Ukrainian troops are learning how to use
hemostatic bandages let's try this a
different way maybe it will work better
that's it good leave the 15 centimeter
strip then bend the adhesive and it's
ready to go
keep that strip on the outside of the
hand and hold it like that
- the press will ignore any searches is
a People's War because it's the
Ukrainian people who are actually doing
the fighting some are at the front
others work in the supply chain when the
guys see that I a woman have brought
them some supplies
it gives them strength meanwhile in
dunya pure Petrovsky natalia and her
family are adjusting well to their new
surroundings the children are even
attending kindergarten but Natalia is
worried about her sister Oksana who's
still in the region controlled by
separatists she has no money and her
daughter is ill Natalia tries to stay in
contact by phone what's going on there
what what's going on there we want to
join you there things are bad here we
want to be with you I can't take this
anymore
Oksana please don't cry
we've talked to some volunteers to bring
families to safety what Lord Jews and
you might serve them as ancient entity
we'll do everything we can to get you
out of there
strange to us is Lisa saying you drive
to do that's gone your own sure good
kiss Vika for us love us to lose all our
love and don't cry we can't stand it
here spoken bondo I'm going to the
neighbors now to get some salts we don't
have any what can you do
Oh
that equals machetes minute purchase
change and there's gonna change in
people's consciousness our nation has
matured because now we can see as we can
change things people deserve a better
life volunteer fighters have given us a
real push forward our government was
financially quite weak and the army was
falling apart ah de miedo Zavala
and if average people hadn't supported
the volunteers who knows how things
would have turned out for us
doctors Niagara La Scala supports an
astonishing moment
Oh such a strong novo cry we're building
a new Ukraine I think our country must
renew itself in every way this includes
creating a legal system that's fair and
humane yeah I'm familiar with the
European legal system and I want to see
it established here but a mechanism you
chose to booboo crania boot or a pc
suitably periodic the other visual foams
are essential and I say that not only as
someone who lives in a big city but also
as someone who works at the front but
it's tough to implement reforms in a
country that's fighting a war year
Ariana's Ovitz at Shimer Naveen
yes vanilla sister impetus tried to call
my sister actually I tried to call her
neighbors who have a mobile phone but I
couldn't get through my beat in their
toes in your blisters but if I also
tried to call a friend of mine who lives
there but I couldn't get through to
anyone when you come home and you Chi
discovered does show you anymore groups
of I need some young is knowledge I
don't know what to do now I have no idea
who I should call all the shots of
Chicanos or anything
it's just but I squandered my usual all
the work that I'm doing now in the
combat zone I'm doing for this city and
for these children such a contrast
between life here and what you see there
just three hours ago I was sitting in a
shelter at the front rockets were flying
over us and we could hear the guns
firing the sounds of war and when we
came back the next day I close my eyes
and I can hear the voices of the
children and the other sounds tuned
laughing like crying
running around the sounds of their bite
yes is when I close my eyes and I hear
all that I remember why I went to the
front yesterday the table will Aradia
you